okay so when you carry forward this
vision which is that you have the
virtuous position and it doesn't matter
what democratic obstacles stand in your
way somebody needs to get out of the way
this takes you to some pretty
anti-democratic places and this has been
true again across the political aid but
right now we are seeing it mostly from
people on the left so bernie sanders for
example over the weekend he tweeted out
two senators cannot be allowed to defeat
what 48 senators and 210 house members
want we must stand with the working
families of our country we must combat
climate change we must delay passing the
infrastructure bill until we pass a
strong reconciliation bill you know just
focus in on those stats for one second
and we are talk we're talking about
anti-democratic beliefs and norms it's
not a surprise that bernie sanders is
fond of anti-democratic norms after all
he loves the ussr and cuba but bernie
sanders tweeting out that two senators
cannot be allowed to defeat but 48
sundays and 210 house members won
this boggles the mind a little bit
considering there are 100 senators
so if 48 senators want something this
would mean
just using a little quick math up top
here 100 minus 48 is 52 that means 52
senators do not want something so he is
saying that joe manchin and kristen
cinema if they don't want something
along with 50 other republicans they
should not be able to trump what 48
senators want
which is a weird notion of how
majorities work
he says they're not allowed to defeat
210 house members what those 210 house
members want now you'll recall there are
435 house members now again i may not be
on math wiz but 435 minus 210 is 225
which is larger than 210. so he's saying
a minority of the house and a minority
of the senate ought to rule
and of course he believes that because
he is privy to virtue
and the process can't be allowed to
stand in the way the process is of no
consequence at all
obviously and this attitude has
permeated down to the lowest levels of
the democratic activist wing
so nancy pelosi put out a notice
last week that they had extended the
thursday september 30th legislative day
to friday pushing back passage of the
bipartisan infrastructure framework and
to advance build back better but they
needed more time to reach their goal she
says quote my time is needed to reach
our goal of passing both bills which we
will it's about time we all take great
pride in the rescue package
it's about time
there's an october 31st surface
transportation authorization deadline
after last night's passage of a critical
30-day extension we must pass biff well
before then the sooner the better to get
the jobs out there it's about time just
keep saying it's about time over and
over and over um if it were about time
then she would have passed a bill last
week she doesn't have the support to
pass the bill last week so instead she's
pushing it off until october 31st she
was supposed to vote on the bipartisan
infrastructure framework right that that
bipartisan infrastructure bill
had support from republicans in the
senate it had support from republicans
in the house
she wasn't going to bring it up for a
vote however because there weren't
enough democrats in her own party to
pass it unanimously within her own party
and they were going to try and vote it
down
so
she instead delayed it and she's falling
prey to the progressives who again are a
very small wing of the party
this caused kristen cinema to blast
fellow democrats she said canceling the
u.s house vote on the bipartisan
infrastructure investment in jobs act
denies americans millions of good-paying
new jobs and hurts everyday families
and she points out that it's the
radicals who are holding this up
she says congress was designed as a
place where representatives of americans
with valid and diverse views find
compromise and common ground that is why
when president biden asked me to
continue bipartisan infrastructure
negotiations i agreed and helped deliver
the bipartisan infrastructure investment
and jobs act a historic broadly popular
plan that reflects a key priority of
president bidens my commitment to
delivering lasting results is also why i
have engaged for months in direct good
faith negotiations over the separate
budget reconciliation proposal good
faith negotiations however require trust
over the course of this year democratic
leaders have made conflicting promises
that could not all be kept and have at
times pretended that differences of
opinion within our party did not exist
even when those disagreements were
repeatedly made clear directly and
publicly cancelling the infrastructure
vote further erodes that trust more
importantly it betrays the trust the
american people have placed in their
elected leaders and denies our country
crucial investments to expand economic
opportunities it's like that's kirsten
cinema going hard after her own party
okay but what this means is that this
means christian cinema is the bad person
and kristin cinema is is apparently
standing in the way of democracy and the
folks who believe that the federal
government should do anything and
everything
that any obstacle is an obstacle on the
road to utopia those people have no
limits
this is how you end up with video of
protesters following kristin cinema into
the bathroom at arizona state university
and berating her while she is on the can
i'm not kidding you this is a thing that
happened over the weekend now just
imagine for a second
if republicans had followed aoc into the
bathroom and berated her about the green
new deal right we would be treated to
weeks on end of talk about the innate
horrors of that right aoc would be on tv
crime and we would have the media
talking about how all republicans were
like this
meanwhile you have democrats who are
chasing kristen cinema into a bathroom
where presumably she is doing her
business in order to harass her about
not voting for a 3.5 trillion dollar
boondoggle
and the media are kind of like
you know normal politics every day at
work here's a little bit of that video
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we
and bernie sanders of course is doubling
down on this as well so bernie sanders
was slamming kirsten cinema saying that
it's not the progressives holding this
up it's kirsten cinema and joe manchin
holding this up well no it's you
it's you i mean these are two separate
issues there's a bipartisan
infrastructure plan which again
has bipartisan approval and then there's
the reconciliation plan which needs to
be negotiated separately you guys tied
them together because you wish to run
roughshod over everyone and that's why
you're angry at cinema because she's
standing in the way of your utopian
schemes here's bernie
well i think senator cinema is is wrong
i think from day one jonathan it has
been clear president of the united
states has said it speaker of the house
pelosi has made it clear our majority
leader in the senate schumer has made it
clear both of these bills are going
forward in tandem we're not just taking
on or dealing with senators mansion or
senator cinema we're taking on the
entire ruling class of this country
it's the higher ruling class of this
country that needs to be taken on right
the language of virtue of pure virtue
democratic norms don't matter democracy
doesn't matter this guy thinks that 48
senators and 210 congress people are
enough to pass a 3.5 trillion dollar
bill what's the big deal after all what
they are doing is virtuous it all comes
down in the end to government power it's
all about government power
right and then
the powerful are entitled to completely
lie to you of course so cedric richmond
is an advisor to president biden he goes
out on national tv and he keeps
repeating the lie that we don't have to
worry about the spending because of
course the number is zero
this is not about a number because at
the end of the day here's what's
important chuck the number is zero
we are paying for everything in this
piece of legislation and it's very
popular with the american people that
the wealthy and big corporations finally
pay their fair share so we're going to
pay for everything we do
no you're not going to pay for
everything you do and you're lying to
the american people but you believe you
can get away with it because for too
long the american people have been
willing to grant absolute power to
whoever quote unquote agrees with them
depending on whether they have a d or an
r next to their name
and that needs to stop right now we need
to start thinking as an american people
systemically you know to start thinking
about the systems and incentive
structures we create for our politicians
this is not about electing the right
people it's not about getting rid of the
wrong people it's about making sure that
the checks and balances of american
government still work to protect the
fundamental freedoms
that are there because human nature
exists and human nature is not
trustworthy the battle for the culture
is heating up we here at the daily wear
are making some big moves so be sure to
like subscribe ring that bell because
you're not going to want to miss a
single moment